[Musique]
ouais
comment ça se passe avec la fille en
question nos mains on a mis seulement
ses coûts sociaux est ce que tu as dit
amoureuse
bah oui mais qui alors quand j'étais au
collège
personnellement je n'avais pas de je
n'étais pas amoureuse a bien que oui
deux fois mais
enfin une fois en tout bien tout honneur
que vous étiez encore au collège
est ce que ce genre de relation et est
approuvé par les jurys quand j'étais en
voyage c'est très vieux setca vieux j'ai
le sentiment quand même que les choses
ont évolué non entrés dans la vie
amoureuse elle est plus précoce bonjour
si ça j'étais amoureuse
[Musique]
je prends peur de la condition de
prendre à toi oui c'est juste pour ça
alors c'est beau comme un dieu gobineau
longtemps longtemps longtemps longtemps
demain j'ai tout pris la chose pour toi
l'amour l'amour
bah je sais pas c'est comme ça
par définition de l'amour pas bon genre
quand tu vas à la personne que tu as mal
au coeur bon bien que six ans risquent
d'être animés par l'envié des mois dans
laissez vous découvrez
l'autre y compris dans les relations
amoureuses que vous pouvez avoir moi je
crois que c'est de votre âge en fait
vous êtes des ados donc c'est normal que
voilà mais cette espèce d'éveil
apparemment lorsque vous sortis ensemble
elle sortait avec 3,4 en même temps oui
j'ai ouais c'est vrai oui ou non ces
gars là ouais tu es gosnay gaz ou sata
fais toi là ce kyste est ce la tristesse
avoir mode cloud
non je vais humblement et ouais bah je
propose pour assise au bar autre est
venu me voir tout va de soi chômage la
ministre
oui mais tu as la mine de l'an à la lime
et la relation amoureuse c'est une
relation d'intimité qui vous appartient
et
d'abord qu'il faut protéger et puis qui
se vit à l'extérieur du collège donc à
l'abri des regards
et puis dans un cadre propice voilà son
exposition qui est l'autre l'autre notre
île est différent de moi ou aller
différente de moi donc apprendre à le
comprendre ou à la comprendre et ça
c'est fondamental il faudrait que
justement la parole soit quelques fois
dans un espace réservé par contre dans
un espace réservé il faudrait
effectivement amené à ce que la parole
soit sans tabou j'aime pas ben oui
pourquoi pas et oui mais je sais pas
mais ça te fait pas peur non si un peu
si j'en ris casse avec toi toi oui parce
qu'hier j'ai déjà des peines de coeur et
toi ça va
agent d'accueil à notre âge on peut
briser le client quoi mais voilà bf1 des
cabines assume ans à venir
en général c'est un petit peu dommage
ils viennent après ils viennent pour
essuyer leurs larmes
je vous vois arriver en classe la mine
défaite en pleurs vous n'arrivez pas à
suivre le cours
et quant à la fin de leur jeu vous je
vous prends part et que je vous demande
alors qu'est ce qui se passait à ce
moment là généralement c'est ce n'est
pas l'élève
concernés qui le dit mais c'est une de
ses camarades qui dit mais madame elle
vient de rompre où il vient de rompre
avant généralement c'est l1 avec leurs
petites amies et je joue un peu c'est
vrai que j'ai un petit côté maternel est
ce qui fait que bon je cherche à
rassurer parce que vous avez besoin
d'être rassurés à ce niveau là aussi est
ce que tu parles de tes peines de coeur
était pas mes parents n'ont pas du tout
parce que c'est pas cache pas le droit
mais comme ils sont ultra protecteur
mais mes soeurs oui un peu et toi je
suis obligé d'en parler pour me sentir
mieux et il te dise quoi qu'on veuille
me disent qu enfin à mon âge ne devrait
pas souffrir autant parce que voilà il
me reste encore beaucoup de chemin à
faire donc que c'est pas le moment
d'avoir ce genre de sentiment et toi tu
penses quoi
baker en fait que l'amour n'a pas d'âge
mais qu'il faut quand même rester sur
ses gardes parce que là on sera pas
pareil un autre âge que dans dix ans
d'azur mais dans dix ans un bel ça sera
plus sérieux ou quoi
j'espère qu'on est ici
l'émotion est passagère le sentiment
normalement il est là pour durer et vous
justement la différence que vous devez
faire c'est savoir si cette personne ne
plaît aujourd'hui et demain ne me plaira
plus est ce que la personne me plaît
pour l'image que j'ai d'être avec elle
dans l'établissement l'y voit l'image
que je renvoie aux autres
est ce que la personne me plaît parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça va pas et qu'elle
m'apporte quelque chose white qui me
plaît vraiment parce que j'ai envie
d'échanger avec cette personne je peux
me donner quelque chose mais elle aussi
elle peut m'apporter quelque chose et
que j'ai envie de continuer avec cette
personne